the sequences for the making of pet
sounds and later good vibrations and
smile we're all really important I mean
for me I kind of grew up on just those
occasional glimpses into you know the
making of an album or something I let it
be or sympathy for the devil that were
you know kind of those rare glimpses and
I really wanted to kind of capture that
real spontaneous authentic look at it so
we ended up shooting at all like a
documentary and had real musicians and
all their and Paul kind of you know
channeling Brian and really doing the
whole thing when it came down to the
good vibrations and I don't know if
you're talking about the 360 pan but
that's actually something that was a
little nod to Godard
with the sympathy for the devil but you
know it worked there to kind of really
communicate I think again Brian's
precision really wanting to get it right
he had these you know amazing melodies
and harmonies and arrangements in his
head and getting it out you know in
exactly the right way was super
important Brian what does the experience
been like to watch this movie and watch
you recreating your mute your music and
well it's broken up to many different
segments and sections the first one that
I liked the most was when I met Melinda
and and bought a car from her and her
dealership Cadillac dealership and then
I went to went to a place called where I
was producing records and I'm bill I
mean paul dano did a great job
portraying me as a record producer it
was a lot of fun it's a labor of love
and I still continue to to watch the
movie I've seen it five times and I
probably see it five more times it's
really a great movie
but I think I read a quote of yours
where you said that your time with dr.
Landy was even worse in real life than
it was in the film actually it was worse
than the film that in real life the guy
that played dr. Landy all gee money was
so letter-perfect I thought that was a
real dr. Landy it was like it was so
factual and so well done that I couldn't
you know couldn't couldn't handle it
yeah I mean one of the the beauties of
playing Brian and that you know Brian is
a part of the project was just the the
wealth of resources that I had so you
know I've never had more fun researching
uh you know apart then then Brian and as
much as I read or looked at or or
whatever I did to try to sort of chase
his spirit around and and just get a
little piece of it without question it
was not just listening to the music and
the Pet Sounds sessions and the smile
sessions that they've released which are
one of the great documentation of an
artist at work that that anyone can hear
but I think learning to play and sing
the songs is what probably brought me
closest to Brian's spirit and I think in
some way by playing and singing you you
are putting Brian inside of you you know
and and so everything seemed to circle
back to the music for me no matter no
matter what I tried it it all came back
to the music was there a particular song
Eureka moment where you were listening
to something or singing something where
it fell into place I think it was the
beauty of the beginning of the song you
still believed in me that the second I
think it's the second track off Pet
Sounds and he sings these sort of
falsetto I was coming down and something
about that because it's not words it's
the voice it's something about it's the
the spirit we could talk about the
instrumentation the chord changes the
you know there's so much going on
Brian's music but the he is the is the
the part that we can't is that is
ineffable and I think you you know I
really feel that in in his voice did you
and John talk about how are you gonna
play these characters or do you want to
go off in Korea
the character at that time in your own
mind no we we we met as I was finishing
and and John was starting and I think
you know we we both really trusted him
bill but Bill really trusted in us to
say you know I think if you guys just go
after your respective Brian spirits that
it's gonna work out and and I think it
does you know for me that juxtaposition
of a young man truly alive and vital in
the studio making Pet Sounds to somebody
older who's clearly been through
something and watching the film we we we
don't know what yet you know there's
there's something in between those two
people then I think is really
interesting and and I think having that
the two actors helps us just to get you
know a percentage of you know a Brian
who's such a beautiful and complicated
human being when my the guy work with
Brian max first called me up about it
and said we're doing you know they're
making this film about Brian Wilson
would you like to be involved doing the
score absolutely no no how can you
possibly compete you know or not compete
but you know you're going to play one of
you know I can think of any number of
songs and then it's written to a bit of
score and it's just going to sound lame
in my opinion and also it wasn't like a
massive fan of the music by Oh Jean it
was once I'd read the script and I
understood what the film was and then I
still felt like it would be a big
challenge but having read it I thought
if Brian was ever present maybe that
would be a way that the music could work
so I met with Bill and we we had
breakfast and and I I told him this idea
I said you know do you think Brian might
give you know certain mythology about
all this music that was recording is
never released and about a month later
these hard drives arrived at my house
and everything Brian kept everything
right is incredibly generous and you
know I hopefully did my best to do a
respectful tone yeah I mean we had
access to an amazing amount of research
and resources I mean Brian and the Beach
Boys life have been so well documented
and we had a jumping-off point with the
studios over there on Sunset which is
now East West which is where the Pet
Sounds track was originally put together
I had this great you know warm earthy
tones started with that and it just
seemed like a natural sort of way to go
with that period and we sort of tried to
embrace that and juxtapose that in the
80s where we definitely was like with a
cooler palette more whites black and
Gray's mirrored surfaces things are a
little gloss here and but even with
those two different eras we tried to was
in every it was a concept that bill
brought up I think our first meeting and
it's it's reflecting the line that
Elizabeth has about um the color blue
being this calm tone and we tried to
sort of weave the whole movie together
with those tones and if you notice that
there's whether it's the blue sky or the
pool or the reflections of the pool in
the house and in in wardrobe that it was
sort of a through line that felt sort of
natural it tied together Danny it feels
like in the in the 60s you're very
authentic
not so much later on why is that well
yeah the 60s part was you know we were
really working from the research and
kind of using it like a jigsaw puzzle to
recreate everything almost exactly as it
was because it's so beautifully
documented and you know the 80s portion
it was it was more about getting into
the kind of the psychological space of
of Melinda and how she's seeing the
world and how Melinda is meeting Brian
and how and so is a lot of fun to sort
of contrast this really kind of
beautiful poppy dreamy California
authentic element
the 60s and then the 80s I kind of was
sort of trying to evoke those sort of
like cool noir 's of the eighties
California Noirs where everything black
would turn white and and I kind of
really loved the idea of white being a
color that was incredibly angelic and
safe as we see but also incredibly cruel
and deceptive the way that Landy
manifests itself in white and it kind of
a part of me wanted to subconsciously
suggest that he escaped from a mental
institution and you sort of but it was
really it was really fun to sort of play
with the balance of of authentic which
both parts were but then the atheist
portion was definitely leaning into sort
of a more visceral emotional
authenticity
I was very seduced by this script and by
the ambition of the two actors and the
two time periods and stringing it all
together but Melinda she was a mystery
little mystery to me until I really met
her and she's so fierce and so devoted
to Brian and Melinda said to me you know
let it it I wanted to understand how you
fall in love with someone with as many
challenges as Brian had in the moment
that they met and Melinda said
everybody's got baggage and that's true
and it's just about your commitment to
overcoming and seeing the the soul of
the other person and they are winning at
life if you go to Brian's home it's a
big beautiful house five kids tons of
dogs tons of laughter love beyond it's
just a beautiful earring a beautiful
life he has completely come out of this
on the other side and I think that's the
message to take away we don't quite you
know we don't tell that in in the movie
it you have to infer it and I'm telling
you there they won they did it
you just meet her and she's just she's a
force to be reckoned with and I think in
some ways in bill this is probably the
design of the film that she's a force to
be reckoned with but Landy really
underestimates what she's capable of
yeah and that's what happened in real
light life to my knowledge there was
quite a struggle there was actually a
bigger stronger than went on that we can
even capture in the movie it was really
you could do a film just about that one
part of the story really I mean she was
very strong and really I don't know
Brian could probably ask answer better
you know where he would be without her
but really I was at ask Brian where
would you be without Melinda without her
god only knows I wrote a song before he
met her now it's about her yeah